he'll people in our profession can light
up a stage as much as the lady I'm about
to introduce an Oscar winner herself
she's known to many as mrs. buddy
fogulson and many more as greer garson
then the interest of impartiality may I
then present miss rear Fogelson
Thank You Leslie ho I'm here tonight to
present a special Oscar voted by the
Board of Governors to the man
responsible for a very special film and
before we ask him to come up here we'd
like you to see just a brief moment from
this film please the Navy can send
special greetings
the mighty Polaris submarine launched
from far at sea to strike and devastate
the target
while aboard ship radar scans and
watches and guards against the enemy as
the amphibious task force closes on the
objective area racing at full speed
toward the target there's a pilot
scramble as Navy and Marine fighter
craft moved to secure the air above
objective to establish protective
umbrella for landing force
as backed by the Navy's firepower
Marines prepared to seize beachhead in
new manner projecting sea power deepest
Shores
we're ready to launch airborne attack
over the beach and beyond past shore
defenses and behind them as employing
vertical assault tactics pilots prepare
for takeoff the landing is on the
citation reads for his outstanding
patriotic service in the conception
writing and production of the Marine
Corps film a force in readiness which
has brought honor to the Academy and to
the motion picture industry and Oscar to
William L Hendricks
Lieutenant Colonel United States Marine
Corps Reserve
congratulations for the Secretary of the
Navy for the Commandant of the Marine
Corps for Marines and sailors everywhere
for all those who contributed to the
making of a force in readiness for
myself thank you
you